in this video we'll be talking about the
valva development in C elegans
C elegans is a worm it's a nematode and
it's a wonderful model organism to study
development and Neuroscience
so C elegans are actually hermaphrodites
that means they have male and female
characteristics in the same body
but initially they are not hermaphrodite
at the early stage of their life they
are males and they have sperms
eventually
these Palms are stored for later use
when it grows older then it develops
ovaries eventually the eggs can trickle
down to that sperm and eventually be
fertilized inside the nematode once
fertilized the egg would eventually be
released from a region known as valva
and these eggs are laid outside
so this is the function of valva and we
would be talking about
the development and the induction of
vulva in C elegans but before we start
we should understand why should we be
bothered about learning a process in C
elegans that is not at all a human
so in that context I would like to
suggest that this particular development
of or induction of valva is a nice
coordination of two fundamental
signaling schemes
paracrine and justocrine signaling
coding it with each other in this
developmental process
just to exemplify these things you can
see paraquin signaling means one cell
secretes something and other cell in a
near vicinity receive that signal using
a receptor and juxtapin signaling means
the cell contacts with another cell with
physical interactions and this happens
with the cell just next to it
just to clarify a little bit in juxta
crane signaling cell cell contact is
important and in paracrine signaling
cell cell contact doesn't happen
directly but via secreted molecule in
that respect the cell which is exactly
near to a source cell can still
interpret it but a cell Which is far
away from the source cell has the
capability to receive the signal
obviously at a varying degree in this
case the cell one would receive more
signals cell 2 would receive less signal
and it depends and it's a function of
the distance
and these two signaling
schemes interact with each other in the
world development of C elegans without
further delay let's Dive In
so this is the overall anatomy of the
vulva in C elegans so here you can see
the gonad
here is a cell which is known as anchor
cell
it has important function and there are
six volval precursor cell which would
eventually give rise to volval cells
now question is how these valuable
precursor cell obtain their future Fates
so the anchor cell is here and all these
six
Volvo precursor cells or VPC are known
as equivalence group that means they
have equal capability or competence to
be induced by the anchor cell simply the
anchor cell is working like an inducer
and all the vpcs are working like a
responder
now let's look at this thing in bit more
details
so all these vpcs are named by specific
nomenclature such as the VPC which is
exactly adjusting to the Anchor cell is
P6 point p6p and thereby p67
then p8p Etc so this is just a
nomenclature but anyway
eventually these cells would give rise
to different uh cell types in the gonads
so obviously the cells which are exactly
in the vicinity of anchor cell becomes
the central vulval cell
the cells which are little bit far away
from the anchor cell eventually takes
the fate of secondary or lateral vulva
cells
and the cells which are far furthest
apart they take the fate of hypodermal
cells
now let's talk about what is the
function of anchor cells anchor cell is
inducer it's a source of morphogen so it
secretes a morphogen known as lean three
so lean three is nothing but a EGF like
molecule lean three secrets from anchor
cell from a concentration dependent
manner so basically a concentration
gradient is set up from the anchor cell
now based on the concentration
there could be different gene expression
modules in different responder cells for
example in p6p cells there is let's say
module one so obviously in P seven P or
p8p cells there are different gene
expression modules which are activated
and this lead to different different
fate so this is the overall outline of
our understanding but we would delve
into detail about the signaling pathway
but the moral of the story is
interpretation of the lintry gradient is
important for Volvo fade specification
now here we are seeing a anchor cell in
the zoomed version and the Volvo
precursor cell so the anchor cell is
secreting the Lin 3 molecule which is
EGF light ligand and the valve wall cell
precursor has EGF receptors which is
also known as lit 23 in C elegans
eventually these cell has a capability
to become a valuable cell so obviously
there are set of genes known as vulvault
genes but in normal circumstances they
are suppressed by lean 1 and lean 31
complexes
so Lin 3 and let 23 mediated map kinase
signaling de-repress this phenomena so
let 23 activates lead 60 which is a Ras
60 eventually activates mpk1 which is a
map kinase and ultimately it leads to
repression of lean one and lean 31. so
basically repressor is derepressed and
that is why now lean 39 can bind and
activate the Volvo genes that lead to
the Fate specification of these falval
precursor cell into one degree Central
wall cells
now you understand the signaling basic
now let's talk about some experiment
that further proves this thing so this
is how this is the wild type scenario
now we are well versed with the
different cell types coming out of these
valuable progenitor cells or precursor
cells
so basically
in a situation when the gonad is ablated
that means the
the anchor cell is gone in that
condition
all of these six cells take up the fate
of hypodermal cell because think in this
way when the anchor cell is gone the
morphogen secretion source is gone that
means each and every cell is forced to
experience a very low level or
negligible level of lean three
and that lead to the conversion of the
fate into hypodermal cells so this kind
of experiment
done in 1981 reinforce the idea that Lim
3 gradient interpretation is really
important for Volvo's fate specification
so there are gene expression thresholds
based on the distance different gene
expression pattern is activated
now let us try to understand the anger
cell the anchor cell secretes lean three
but why why not any other cell secretes
lean three
how anchor cell is defined at the first
place to be an anchor cell it turns out
in early stage of C Elegance development
there are two cell types known as Z1
triple p and Z4 Triple A each of this
cell has a capability to become anchor
cell
but one of them take the anchor sulphate
and the other cell does not take Bank of
sulfate and it takes a ventral uterine
precursor fate so
how can one cell choose one Fit versus
the another and they can interact in a
manner
which is basically known as lateral
inhibition and they can force one cell
to not become or not choose one fate and
this is basically a juxtapanine
signaling that we'll be talking about
so let's see what happens
so let me remind you again there could
be secret secreted signal by which two
cells can be interacting or there could
be contact based signaling we are now
talking about the contact based
signaling which are mediated by Notch
and Delta pathway so lag 2 is basically
Delta in CA elegance and Lin 12 is the
notch
so initially there are different models
which can suggest how this specification
happens in terms of anchor cell
so initially both these cells has equal
level of Notch and Delta and there is a
stochastic event where one cell
surprisingly has slightly more
Delta than the other cell
so there is a dis minute disproportion
between Notch and Delta levels in these
two cell
and this kind of differences are further
reinforced and become prominent now one
cell entirely secretes Delta and another
cell forms the notch
and eventually this
distinctions are reinforced to generate
the anchor cells and the other second
fate
so two things are really important in
this case first the initial difference
between the two cells was created due to
chance its stochastic event
and then second the initial difference
once created is reinforced by feedback
loops that lead to different fate choice
in this case
so this Notch Delta mediated mechanism
of restricting adjacent cell fate is
actually called the lateral inhibition
let us try to understand this in bit
more details
and this happens this kind of lateral
inhibition also works in the FED
specification of valuable precursor so
anchor cell is secreting the lean three
molecule already we have shown and here
we are seeing three cells adjacent to
the Anchor cell the cell in the center
experience the highest level of Lin 3
and the cells which are in the sides
experience relatively lower level of
lean three so obviously there would be a
lean three mediated rasmap kinase
pathway which would ultimately lead to
the production of one degree Central
vulval cell fit genes
also the same pathway triggers the
production of Delta
so Delta lead to the in Delta actually
interacts with notch in the adjacent
cell
now let 23 level let 23 levels are
relatively similar in all these cells
because they were equally competent but
lean 3 experienced by the corner cells
are less so obviously the signaling arm
is now different
so a different component of the rasmap
kinase pathway is activated which
involves rgl1 rel1 but eventually it
lead to production of the secondary fed
genes it's also important to note that
the Delta and Notch interaction
reinforces or triggers the activity of
the secondary fade genes not the primary
one so obviously once this you can
clearly see once the central cell
becomes the one degree volval cell it
prevents the other cell in its near
vicinity to take the same fate and it's
forcing the other cell to take an
alternative fate
so one side there is differential
inductive signal so every cell is
experiencing different levels of
morphogens and on the other hand side
there are lateral inhibition that means
one cell took a fate the other cell is
unable to take the fade because the cell
that took the Fate is repressing that
particular phase that means once one
degree fate was
committed the one degree fit is
inhibited in the nearby cell and they
are forced to take the second option the
second degree valve wall cells this is
how a brilliant coordination between the
juxta crane signaling and the paracrine
signaling happens in the development or
induction of the vulval effect
specification in C elegans so I hope
this was useful if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe you can
follow us on Facebook or Instagram all
the links are in description support our
Channel using super tanks and see you in
next video